it's a lucrative deal made between
enemies Israel appeared on the verge of
signing an agreement for natural gas
production off the Mediterranean Coast
with Lebanon which refuses to recognize
the state on its Southern border but
both sides had agreed the U.S brokered
pact is too profitable not to sign but
on Thursday Israeli Prime Minister yair
lapid rejected last-minute changes
requested by Lebanon sending both sides
back to the negotiating table where each
has strong incentive to come to an
agreement
this is a deal that strengthens Israel's
security and economy for lapid starting
production on the carriage oil field as
soon as this month would Mark a much
needed economic and diplomatic Victory
ahead of the November 1st election and
bring Israel closer to energy
Independence for Lebanon splitting
revenue from the neighboring Kona gas
field would mean desperately needed
income for an economy so devastated that
banks have closed after cash-strapped
customers resorted to carrying weapons
to forcibly withdraw their own money a
tremendous economic uh problem at the
moment
and we want to have hospice Neighbors
not Neighbors on the on the verge of
bankruptcy there is an unofficial third
party In the Mix Hezbollah the
iranian-backed group in Lebanon whose
leader has spoken favorably of the deal
that's a dramatic change from the high
tensions of June when the Israeli Prime
Minister threatened to begin gas
production without a deal and Hezbollah
sent three drones to the carriage site
all shot down by Israel adding to a
growing possibility of an armed
confrontation with production platforms
sitting idly in the Mediterranean sun
lepid has little time to forge a deal in
time for it to help his chances in the
November first Israeli election I think
it's a good chance by the way they've
already began drilling the only thing to
do now is to turn on the tap turn on the
spigot and let the gas roll if the two
sides can agree that would clear the way
for natural gas to start flowing from
the Israeli Lebanon Border in a matter
of days proving that economics could
well bring a grudging cooperation where
diplomacy is not John hendren Al Jazeera
West Jerusalem